hello and welcome today we're going to
be
looking at what exactly happens when you
do an
operation such as addition on two numpy
arrays of different shapes
by the end of this video you're going to
understand why in this case you should
expect a three by three array
and you're going to understand where
those numbers come from and you're going
to understand
what you would need to do differently if
you actually wanted to just
add number by number zero plus three one
plus four
two plus five so what is array
broadcasting
array broadcasting is a way to do
element-wise
operations on arrays of possibly
different but compatible shapes
for example in this case i have a matrix
with two rows and three columns
and i have a single row of three numbers
in this case it's pretty clear that i
can simply add this row
one two three to the top row and the
bottom row
when i add it to the top row i get 1 3 5
and when i add it to the bottom row i
get
4 6 8. similarly if i added a column
1 2 instead of a row then i would just
add that column to each column
this idea works with any kind of
element-wise operation that you would
want to do
on arrays so you can think plus minus
times
exponentiation taking the minimum or
maximum element-wise
or lots of other different functions if
you're not sure
whether a certain function uses this
kind of array broadcasting just search
for the word broadcast
in its numpy documentation before we can
go on to decide
what it would actually mean to add these
two different arrays in a more general
context
first we have to understand what it
means for the shapes of these two things
to be compatible
obviously i can add one two three as a
row
but would i be able to add one two 3 4
as a row
well no that doesn't really make sense
and it's kind of obvious
why but it's still hard to explain
so here are the rules for determining if
the shapes of two arrays are compatible
it might look like a lot at first but
stick with me i promise we're going to
do a lot of examples and once you see a
few examples the rules are going to be
crystal clear
first off if one of the arrays has more
dimensions than the other
then when you look at their shapes you
should right align them and imagine
prepending ones
to the shorter one so if you had an
array
which is just three numbers then you
could just as well think about it as a
one by three array or a one by one by
three array or
a one by one by one by three array it
doesn't matter how many ones you prepend
to the front of the shape
that doesn't change that there's just
three numbers in there the next rule
is that if an axis has just a single
element in it
then you can repeat or broadcast that
axis to the length of the other vector's
axis all remaining axes must have the
same lengths
so using these rules we'll be able to
compute whether arrays are compatible
and if so
what the broadcasted shape the results
of the broadcasted operation will be
again these look a little complex but
once you see the examples
it'll clear right up
so here's the first example we start
with
an x that we assume has shape two by
three of course
something with the exact same shape must
be compatible
so in this case another two by three
array would be compatible
but there are definitely other things
that are compatible
so we could have a two by one array and
we see that that's compatible because
the twos match and then one can match
with anything so the one matches with
the three that's okay
similarly a one can match with a two and
a three can match with the three
those are compatible and whenever you
see something that's
shorter than the other one you prepend
ones until they're the same length
so you should imagine that it looks like
this in which case
it's the same as the previous thing the
one matches with the two and the three
with the three
so in that way if i have an array of
just three elements that still matches
with a two by three array
in this case the broadcasted shape is
going to be two by three
now what are some examples of things
that are not compatible
well a three by two is not compatible
because a three
doesn't match a two and also a two
doesn't match a three
we are not allowed to reorder the axes
when checking for compatibility
in this last example you might think
that
it would be compatible because it's like
a two by one
but not so the rule is always to prepend
ones
so if i do that i add one at the
beginning not the end
in that case i would have something that
looks like one by two
the one matches with the two but the two
does not match with the three so they're
not compatible
if you wanted to do 2 comma 1 instead
you would just have to reshape y using
the dot reshape method
let's look at another set of examples
in this case we have 4 dimensions and we
see that all of the following things are
compatible
in every case we follow the same rules
again though
in this case we cannot append a one to
make it compatible
we always prepend ones so far we've only
seen examples
where the resulting shape is the same as
one of the original shapes let's look at
an example where that is not the case
in this example we have quite different
looking shapes but they are in fact
compatible
you can see in this case that i've
already right aligned them
and that they match up every entry
either is the same number
or has a one in the column
and then of course i would just prepend
ones in this space
but i'll leave that out so the way that
we're getting the common shape
is to take either the common number in
this case 17
or one or if only one of the numbers is
1
then take the number that's not that so
we would take 17 here 1 here 11 here
7 here 5 here and then 3 2 and 1.
so now you should be able to tell just
by looking at the shapes of the two
arrays
whether they're compatible and if so
what the resulting shape should be
but i still haven't told you how to
actually add two things of different
shapes
to do that all we have to do is imagine
a for loop the idea
is that for any dimension where
you used a one to match a different
dimension
then instead of looping over that
variable just use index 0 because that's
the only valid index
in this case i have a 3x3 and a 3x1
so we check that the shapes are
compatible 3 matches with 1
and three matches with three the
resultant shape should be three by three
i then create an empty array of that
shape and i'm going to
use nested for loops to fill in
the values of course actually using
these for loops would be
a bad idea because for loops in python
are extremely slow
but to understand what value numpy is
actually computing when you do this
this is what you should be thinking of
okay so in order to fill out the ijth
entry
of our output array just think
that you want to do element-wise
addition
but when it's not possible fill things
in
in the best possible way x has shape
3 3 so it makes sense to give
i and j as indices to the x array
y on the other hand was 3 by 1. so
it makes sense to pass in the i index
which goes from zero to two
but i can't pass in the j index here
because that axis only has one element
it only has one valid index
so just use it if i go ahead and run the
code
we see that the output is the same as
what numpy gave
let's take a look at another example
this example shows how to think about it
when you had
one array that didn't have as many
dimensions as the other
and the rule here is just omit the
variables whenever you prepended ones to
the dimension
in this case i have x which is a two by
three by three
which is essentially it's two three by
three matrices there's one
and there's the other and i have a
single
three element array we right align the
dimensions
and we can tell that they're compatible
three three three matches one and two
matches one
and the resultant shape is two by three
by three
this time i have three nested loops
because the shape is three dimensional
to figure out what goes in the ijk spot
of the output array
we just look at what to do for each
element x has no problem because it has
shape two by three by three but with y
there's only one dimension so what to do
with the first two dimensions
well since they were pretended to be
length 1
anyway all we were going to do is plug
in 0s there so let's just omit them
the way that i know to plug in k here
instead of i or j
is that i'm thinking of this column as
corresponding to i
this column is corresponding to j and
this column as corresponding to k
so you can see that for y i have enough
dimensions to plug in the index
again when i run the code you can see
that the output of
the numpy calculation is identical to
the output
created using the for loops
in this final example let's look back at
the one that we started with
on the title slide we had a three by one
array
and a one by three array this highlights
the fact that you can have
ones in either of the arrays not just
one of them
by now we can calculate the compatible
shape
three matches with one and three matches
with one
so the resultant shape will be three by
three
so we create an empty array of that
shape and loop over the two dimensions
the output at i j is computed as follows
the first dimension corresponds to i and
we know
that in that dimension x has the same
shape as the output
so it makes sense to plug in the index i
there
but for j x only has one thing in it
so let's just use the only valid index
0.
on the other hand for y it is the i
dimension
that only has one valid index so we plug
in zero
but for the j dimension we can plug in
the index j
so now we see where this three by three
answer comes from
and you can check that our answer is the
same as the numpy one
so now can you tell what would you do if
you wanted to just add
zero and three one and four and two and
five
well the answer is you would just
reshape one of them you could either
reshape this one
to one by three or this one to three by
one
or both of them just to a three element
array
well i hope this video helped you
understand a little bit better about
what
numpy array broadcasting is and why it
gives you the answers that it does
if you're looking to test your skills a
little bit here's an exercise for you
suppose you have a thousand images that
are 32 by 32 pixels
and each image has three color channels
so it's your standard red green and blue
pixel values from 0 to 255. so
every pixel has a red value a green
value and a blue value
now suppose you have all this image data
stored in a single
array of size ncwh
here n is your 1000 images
c is the three channels w is the width
and
h is the height so my question for you
is
what array y would you multiply by to
scale
every red pixel by 2 every green pixel
by 3
and every blue pixel by four if you want
to check your answer
check out the github link in the
description which has the source code
for this notebook
thanks for watching don't forget to like
comment
and subscribe